deep in the heart of rest in Virginia
lies one of the most powerful
influential yet secretive family
dynasties in America this family Dynasty
is behind the construction of Mega
projects like the Hoover Dam the
underwater Channel tunnel between
England and France they helped the U.S
military build and maintain their
nuclear ICBM bases they managed the
infamous Los Alamos laboratory where the
nuclear bomb was created while
simultaneously building oil
infrastructure for some of the world's
most notorious governments like Saddam
Hussein's Iraq Gaddafi's Libya and of
course the Saudi royal family they even
profited off of Hurricane Katrina and
this family has been deeply embedded
with the CIA Department of Defense and
the department of energy since the
beginning with some of their board
members filling some of the highest
positions in governments from the
Secretary of Defense to the Secretary of
States to the Secretary of Energy which
is a nice sounding title for the person
at the helm of America's nuclear power
and nuclear weapons the New York Times
is quoted saying no other private
Corporation in modern history has had
closer ties to the federal government
than this one which means this this
Corporation has profited off of
practically every major geopolitical
event over the last 100 plus years in
fact it's safe to say that this
Corporation single-handedly built the
modern world as we know it they've
become the biggest construction company
in the world and yet you have never
heard of their name
out of all the secretive family
dynasties we've covered on this channel
this one is by far one of the most
secretive nowhere else have we seen a
family so influential so
all-encompassing and yet so elusive at
the same time with the internet being
almost completely scrubbed of their name
why because no other Corporation has
profited off of War third world
countries and natural disasters quite as
much as this one stay dangerous and say
hello to Beto the secretive family that
engineered the world
[Music]
one thing the wealthy Elite like Bechtel
invests in are financial advisors and
you may be thinking but Jake why would
you want a financial advisor well for me
once I started making a little bit more
money I quickly realized that making
money is one thing but knowing how to
preserve and grow money is a whole
different ballgame I never learned
whether I should have a Roth IRA or a
401k or how much I should contribute to
those or what kind of insurance I should
get that's when I realized that I needed
someone to advise me on the stuff who
ideally has a legal responsibility to
act in my best interests a financial
advisor but financial advisors typically
cost thousands of dollars a year that is
where domain money comes in domain money
gives you your own Certified Financial
Advisor who can help you with your
investing savings Insurance taxes Family
Planning offer just 79 a month with no
hidden fees or investment minimums
basically domains advisors can help you
avoid stress so you can focus on just
the things that matter they don't use
jargon and they give you the best
possible advice for a fraction of the
cost also domain has a 5 apy savings
account and it will prepare and file
your taxes pretty cool if you want to
see if domain money is right for you
click the link below and book your free
30 minutes session with a domain advisor
today click the link below to book a
call now thanks to domain money for
being the paid sponsor of this video
born into a lower class farming family
in Illinois in 1872 there was nothing
Warren Bechtel wanted more than to
escape his life of back-breaking work in
poverty and he finally got that chance
when he married Clara the daughter of a
wealthy family in Indiana with help from
his new father-in-law Warren went into
the cattle business where he thought he
could make a fortune but he thought
wrong by the end of the 19th century
both of America's cattle and Corn
markets have bottomed out and both he
and Clara went bankrupt desperate to dig
himself out of the hole he was in Warren
began transporting material for Railway
companies that were expanding through
the West with his own team of meals he
began making up to 2.75 cents a day or
around 90 a day in today's money and his
time on the railways taught him more
than any engineering degree could
noticing his hard work and skill in
handling construction equipment Warren
was offered her job working on the very
same Railways he was moving material for
and it didn't take him long to stand out
every set he made working his new job he
put it into buying and renting his own
construction equipments and by 1906
thanks to a loan from his father-in-law
he was ready to start working for
himself slowly Warren's company known
simply as Bechtel grew in size and
reputation by the time the Ford Motor
Company began Mass producing their
iconic Model T cars Warren bechtel's
Company was one of the few companies
capable of building all the New Roads
that those cards would need to drive on
and from there it was nowhere but up for
Bechtel by 1936 Bechtel built the Hoover
Dam by World War II Becca was building
ships for the US governments and by the
end of the war Beto developed his love
for all things nuclear winning two
contracts to build two nuclear power
plants in two years Bechtel had
pioneered a whole new business model for
construction companies called TurnKey
contracts where Bechtel would handle
everything from the design and planning
to the construction and delivery of
projects for a fixed fee by the middle
of the 20th century Bechtel was already
one of the biggest family-run
construction companies in America but
Bechtel was hungry for more it didn't
want to just conquer America it wanted
to go Global and to do that it would
have to join the big leagues and since
only the most ruthless and ambitious
companies reached the top that's what
Bechtel had to become
[Music]
um
in 1947 President Harry Truman created a
brand new intelligence apparatus
designed to push America's interests
around the world the CIA and right from
the start Beto saw the CIA as an
opportunity to blur the line between
what was best in the country and what
was best for the company in 1951 Steve
Bechtel was a founding member of the
National Committee for a free Asia an
organization created to counteract
communism overseas and what was a
construction Mobile doing on a committee
to fight communism in Asia a continent
that happened to need a lot of
construction who knows but what we do
know is that this organization would be
later exposed as a CIA front in return
for his great work Steve was appointed
as the CIA Ace of liaison with the
Business Council and that's when the
interests of the CIA and Bechtel started
looking a lot more similar by 1953 Steve
Beto had become close friends with the
infamous CIA director Alan Dulles but by
1961 Alan Dallas was outs and who
replaced them as the director of the CIA
why none other than John McCone an
ex-bettle and engineer and one of Steve
bechtel's closest friends this was at
the height of the Cold War when the CIA
was overthrowing government's left and
rights when it was launching coups left
them right all over the world and now
Bechtel had a company man at the top of
all of us so every time governments were
overthrown every time the IMF and World
Bank went into these poor countries to
offer them infrastructure loans who do
you think awarded these lucrative
contracts to build the dams to build the
power plants come like Bechtel within
just a few short years got those men and
the CIA and U.S governments got it
contracts not just in America but all
across the middle east Europe and South
America as well eventually the US
government CA and beta were so close
that Beto became known as the working
arm of the CIA Beto would come to employ
some of the most influential government
officials of the 20th century while the
CIA and U.S government would come to
employ some of Beto's brightest minds
too George Schultz worked as the U.S
treasury secretary under Nixon in 1972.
two years later he left the government
to become an executive and later the
chairman of Bechtel the first non-family
member to hold a position in his history
just a few years later he went back into
the government as the Secretary of State
in 1982 and when his time as Secretary
of State ended he went right back into
bechdol serving as a director until
2006. another name on the list Casper
Weinberger worked as vice president and
general counsel to Bechtel for five
years before being appointed to U.S
Secretary of Defense in 1981. you know
the guy that oversees the U us War
Machine second only to the Presidents
even Riley bechdol the guy in charge of
Bechtel from 1989 to 2017 was appointed
to President Bush's export Council while
he was still running the company now you
may be thinking isn't it a major
conflict of interest to take Executives
from a company that relies on government
contracts and appoint those Executives
to the government that's supposed to be
giving out those contracts yes yes it is
Bechtel was building harbors and oil
refineries in Kuwait they were advising
the king of Saudi Arabia on his
construction plans but that still wasn't
enough and America Bechtel had become
known for its Mega projects projects
people thought were impossible but made
billions of dollars in profits so if
Bethel really wanted to make a name for
herself and conquer the Middle East just
like it did with America it would need a
contract just as big just as expensive
and just as impossible as the ones it
had done in America and so Bechtel set
his sights on Iraq
foreign
Beto's history in Iraq stretches back to
the 1950s when the Iraq petroleum
company hired it to build an oil
pipeline between Iraq and Syria but then
when Saddam Hussein became president in
1979 doing business with the government
became close to Impossible while other
American companies just packed their
bags and left Bechtel saw befriending
Iraq's dictator as an irresistible
challenge if it could convince Saddam
Hussein to let an American company build
a brand new oil pipeline from Iraq to
Jordan Bethel wouldn't just make
billions of dollars in profits it would
become an American hero the one company
that got America back into Iraq's oil
fields the only problem was there was no
reason for Saddam Hussein to listen or
care about anything Bethel had to say he
was too busy making war with Iran if
Bechtel wanted to get into Iraq it
wouldn't need some help luckily it had
just a guy George Schultz remember our
guy George the one who was the chairman
of Bechtel before becoming the U.S
Secretary of States well as Secretary of
States he was in the perfect position to
help Bechtel catch saddam's attention so
in 1983 while the U.S government was
receiving almost daily reports that's
the dumb Hussein was attacking his own
people with chemical weapons George
called up his old friend Donna runsfield
for a special little mission to Iraq at
the time runsfield was working as an
unpaid part-time employee and special
Envoy to the Middle East but he was
exactly the guy George Schultz could
trust with such a sensitive job his
mission traveled to Iraq and try to make
peace with Saddam Hussein but at the
same time float the idea of letting
Bechtel build a giant oil pipeline to
Jordan Beto has so much influence over
the American government that it was
literally sending U.S officials to other
countries just to get Bechtel more
contracts ultimately Saddam decided not
to let bector or anyone else build the
oil pipeline because of the risk of
Israel blowing it up but Beto has
succeeded at one thing they has saddam's
attention any company strong enough to
get the American government to do its
bidding was a company that Saddam wanted
to know more about so Saddam offered
Bechtel another project Saddam wanted
Beto to construct PC2 a petrochemical
plant that would process millions of
barrels of Iraqi oil but this
petrochemical plant would also buy total
coincidence be able to produce the
chemicals he needed to make his chemical
weapons so obviously Bechtel turned on
the job rights no you see building the
PC2 plant would make them a whopping 2.5
billion dollars in Revenue in just the
first phase alone and sure it was no oil
pipeline or whatever but didn't 2.5
billion dollars have such a nice ring to
it so even though Beto and the US
government knew the PC2 plan would be
used to create deadly chemical weapons
Bechtel went forward with it anyways
with America's blessing for a while it
looked like Bechtel was about to become
saddam's favorite foreign Construction
Company who knew what other projects He
will offer them if they did well on this
one beta was well on their way to
getting their oil pipeline or any other
project they wanted out of him
but then Iraq invaded Kuwait as soon as
it happened America told Saddam Hussein
to withdraw big mistake in saddam's view
America was siding with Kuwait and that
meant bad news for Bechtel out of
nowhere Iraqi police officers started
arresting Bechtle employees if you're
hearing for their safety Bethel withdrew
from Iraq leaving the PC2 plant
unfinished Bechtel was Furious they have
spent a lot of money and called in a lot
of favors to get into Iraq and now it
had all been for nothing back to one of
Revenge back to one of his money back so
Beto went back to good old George shows
and Donald runsfield for help only this
time instead of cozying up to Saddam
Hussein and trying to get on his good
side bethel's asked his Pals to do the
exact opposite and wanted the American
government to get rid of Saddam Hussein
once and for all and it didn't take long
for that wish to come true
[Music]
this hour American and Coalition forces
during the early stages of military
operations to disarm Iraq to free its
people and to defend the world from
grave Danger in 2003 with Donald
runsfield as Secretary of Defense
America invaded Iraq looking for
saddam's alleged weapons of mass
destruction and Bechtel couldn't believe
his luck as a construction company
nothing made Bechtel quite as happy as
the prospect of rebuilding everything
America was about to destroy so while
American bombs were dropped across Iraq
destroying important infrastructure and
flattening entire neighborhoods Bethel
reached out to his government contacts
to get a head start on those Nifty
little reconstruction contracts just
days after the bombing started the US
government announced his plans to
rebuild Iraq and obviously who better
for the government to turn to than their
partner in figurative crime Bechtel so
less than one month one month after
America invaded Iraq usaid awarded
battle won an 18-month Construction
contract worth up to 680 million dollars
less than six months later that budget
was raised to more than 1 billion over
the next few years the US government
will give Bechtel billions more in
reconstruction contracts every time a
U.S bomb destroyed a water Pipeline Road
or School Bechtel would be right there
ready build it up again in an attempt to
make the process more fair the
government agreed to pay each U.S
contractor in Iraq a guaranteed 10 Cost
Plus profits that means whatever it
costs Bechtel to reconstruct the road
schools and hospitals the government
would give them a 10 fee on top of that
but what the government didn't plan for
is for these contractors like Bechtel to
start overcharging for everything if
they're going to get 10 profit on
whatever they spent they might as well
spend as much as possible the more the
materials tools and workers cost the
more profit they would make so Bechtel
was raking in billions while not having
much to show for it instead of using
that money for better security or
Quality Construction they cut back on
their real cause as much as possible
doing their best to pocket every last
cent they could in the three years Beto
operated in Iraq they only finished
about half of the work they were paid
for they blend it on unstable working
conditions and security risks but the
truth is that they never really needed
to finish anything they had already been
paid their customer was the US
government not the Iraqi people who
would actually be using this
infrastructure so for three years Bethel
milled the Iraqi station like a cash cow
and then in 2006 with billions of
dollars and too many workers being
killed or kidnapped Bechtel bailed
Bechtel had gone allakota of Iraq and
now it was time to find another
opportunity a little bit closer to home
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
2000 and Bolivia is in chaos for years
the Bolivian government had been
struggling to supply all the citizens
with water with a GDP of just 8 billion
dollars and almost 40 of the country
living in extreme poverty this was no
easy task one of Bolivia's biggest
issues was that the middle and higher
income homes that had water were wasting
it while the government owned utility
companies were too corrupt to have any
money left for expansion or maintenance
luckily the World Bank had an easy
solution if the government couldn't give
water to the people they would just have
to privatize it get private companies to
take over the distribution of water and
construction of pipelines private
companies wouldn't be afraid of raising
race to cover as cost and on the surface
it seems like a reasonable arguments the
World Bank knew that pushing up water
rates would probably cause some serious
backlash to get the job done it would
need a Cutthroat nasty money-hungry Mega
corporation that wouldn't be afraid of a
little public resistance to their plans
and who better than Bechtel so in
November 1999 a Consortium of companies
led by beptul bid on the contract of
privatized water in kokobamba Bolivia's
four flood largest city in exchange for
2.5 billion dollars the Beto Consortium
would spend the next 40 years upgrading
the city's water supply it was a massive
win for Bechtel but in the eyes of the
people the government had just handed a
foreign company the one thing that they
needed most fresh clean water suddenly
rumors started spreading that Bethel
would be installing water meters on
Wells and they would start privatizing
the rain by charging Farmers for
collecting rain water and all that
expansion the company promised it wasn't
going to pay for all of it oh no the
residents of kokobama would be paying
for everything most people in the city
could barely afford food let alone pay
for water meters or pipelines to be
built but Bechtel didn't care this was
business not a charity So within just a
few months back to almost double
kokobama's water rates suddenly water
bills that were already difficult to
afford now took up almost a quarter of
most people's salaries and when people
complained that they wouldn't be able to
afford it all Bechtel did was threatened
to shut their water supply off
Obama had had enough so starting in
early January 2000 hundreds of thousands
of protesters took to the streets
everyone from Sweatshop workers to
Farmers to retirees rioted against the
rate hikes that had made their lives
literally unaffordable in a matter of
hours was started as a cost of living
protest turned into a full-on water war
with residents battling the police and
the Army in the streets protesters
barricaded all roads into the City and
took over the Central Plaza and a 1.800
police officers even joined in on a
protest firing tear gas canisters Apple
Living soldiers it looked like the
beginning of a full-on revolution so if
the government wanted to survive Bechtel
would have to go so by mid-april the
Beto Consortium abandoned kokobamba
leaving behind billions of dollars in
potential revenue and what's becco's
losses in Iraq and Bolivia racking up
they needed to make some cold hard cash
fast
thank you
on August 29 2005 Hurricane Katrina made
landfall in the U.S for millions of
people across the country the hurricane
ruined their lives their loved ones were
killed their homes destroyed and they
lost everything they owned in the
flooding but while millions of Americans
were trying to pick up the pieces of
their broken lives a select few
companies saw an opportunity to profits
and Iraq Beto I learned just how
profitable destruction could be for a
company in the business of building
things back up and Hurricane Katrina was
no difference the hurricane had barely
reached New Orleans when the US
government reached out to bechtol to
manufacture mobile homes for a hundred
thousand people and just like before it
was a no-bid contract meaning that no
one else was competing with Beto on
price or delivery times it was like
handing Bethel a blank check and telling
them to go nuts which is exactly what
happened instead of building the mobile
homes itself back those subcontract
almost every aspect of his work to other
companies for a fraction of what it was
charging the governments so if it costs
subcontractors five thousand dollars to
build a mobile home beta would charge
the government double and that wasn't
even the worst of this even even though
Bethel was making an insane amount of
profit off of these homes it didn't care
if any of them were finished by the end
of the contracts thousands of Unfinished
mobile homes were left standing empty in
Arkansas but Bechtel wasn't alone almost
every other contractor involved in
Hurricane Katrina over a church and
under delivered on their contracts in
the end it will cost American taxpayers
over 170 billion dollars to repair the
damage from the hurricane 170 billion
dollars that ended up in the pockets of
companies like Bechtel
[Music]
thank you
over the past 125 years Bechtel has been
involved in some of the biggest
construction projects in the world they
restore Kuwait oil fields after they
were set Ablaze during the Iraqi
invasion they put the Hanford waste
treatment plant in Washington to dispose
of radioactive waste they built the
ivanpas solar power system which is the
biggest solar facility in the world they
build Jew Bill industrial city in Saudi
Arabia which was the biggest waste of
government money in history the Athens
Metro system and even the new show that
includes the Chernobyl reactor and there
are probably many more military
installations they built that are top
secrets just imagine the Reconstruction
contracts they're getting right now for
Ukraine but their public projects are
all we really know about them and the
Bechtel family is going to keep it that
way
and you want to know who else is going
to keep it that way Bill and Hillary
Clinton see the clintons also have their
own set of Dark Secrets see in the spin
of around three decades more than 50
people connected to the Clans have died
50 people and these 50 people all
magically died in one of the three ways
suicide plane crash or robbery gone
wrong just those three and why did all
of these people die well one reason
could be that all these people had dirt
on the clintons that could have ruined
their political careers we're talking
about corruption sexual harassment the
whole nine yards but now there can be
only all dead and all these deaths
magically came to an end after Clinton
left the White House and we expose it
all in our new private documentary The
Clinton kill list that you can watch
right now by clicking the card on the
screen one member said that this is by
far the bossiest content that anyone's
ever strung together they kill
investigators and I technically
investigated them here so click the card
on the screen to watch now
thank you